These deep sea mushroom-shaped organisms don’t
fit in any known subdivision of the animal
kingdom.
They’re flat discs and a stalk with a mouth
on the end and are kinda like corals and comb
jellies but not exactly so researchers are
baffled.
And Airbus is patenting virtual reality sensory
isolation headgear which aside from audio
visual components include squirting smells
up passengers’ noses.
So you can completely forget you're flying
in an airplane.
Vsauce!
Kevin here.
This is Mind Blow.
Meta augmented reality glasses make science
fiction a reality.
They use the natural world as the focus of
the computer interface - creating a real-time
map of your surroundings and allowing you
to interact with holograms.
It’s the first machine to allow two people
to view and interact with digital information
from different perspectives while holding
eye contact - so for instance you could play
Minecraft with a friend in the same physical
space.
The interface is designed by the same guy
who did the Iron Man movies and they hope
to implement this in everything from healthcare
and engineering to education and gaming.
Jake from Vsauce3 tried them on and said this...
Quant e-Sportlimousine is a spots car that
runs on salt water.
It has a top speed of 217 mph and uses an
electrolyte flow cell power system to power
four electric motors.
Electrical power for the drive train is created
by using salt water as an electrolyte and
the solution is held in two 200-litre tanks
allowing you to drive up to 373 miles on a
single charge.
And they just received approval to test it
on roads in Europe.
UCLA biologists successfully used a genetic
'remote control' to slow the aging process.
By activating a gene in the nervous system
or intestines of fruit flies they can see
the aging process slow and they hope this
research can eventually be used to delay the
onset of diseases in humans.
It turns out Stonehenge is way bigger than
we thought.
Using radar, laser scanners and magnetometers,
researchers uncovered 17 new chapels, ritual
shrines, massive pits and a 108 foot long
burial mound containing a gigantic wooden
building that they believe was used for rituals
involving dead bodies.
These new findings drastically change our
understanding of Stonehenge which was reshaped
for hundreds of years beginning in 3100BC.
4MM is a jetpack for runners.
Developed at Arizona State University, it
enhances human speed and agility with the
goal of allowing any soldier to run a four
minute mile.
DARPA asked for assistance in developing augmented
ability exoskeletons for able-bodied soldiers
and trials of the jetpack have shown its ability
to make users run faster while exerting less
energy.
This shape-shifting architecture concept expands
and contracts based on temperature.
It uses Shape Memory Polymer joints connected
to plywood to expand the original surface
area four times.
The idea is to create architecture that isn’t
so rigid and is more attuned to the environment
but they admit real world applications on
a large-scale are a ways off.
New ultralight ceramic cubes could be used
to build lighter, stronger airplanes, trucks
and batteries.
The nanoscale struts can recover from being
crushed and they’re light enough to float
through the air.
Ceramic usually shatters when dropped due
to its weight but at the nanoscale the material
is recoverable from compression - and they’re
now working to apply this nanostructure design
to lithium-air batteries.
Finally, Eye Know uses streetlights and time-lapse
to create a kaleidoscope of Tokyo.
I’m gonna leave you with smart headlights
that can adapt to any conditions at highway
speeds.
And as always - thanks for watching.